one hello everyone what's up welcome to
simulation I'm your host down sockin
just finished up with IBM's on Amiga
Guha and now we are on to dr. Aubrey de
Grey I love that hello thank you
appreciate you coming on the show Aubrey
was actually our first guest in October
of 2017 at a live event the first guest
on simulation we really appreciated you
coming out it was a good packed like 120
some people we had a great time Aubrey
was a I remember your your skepticism
towards the bucket of questions that's
what we had at the time it was very good
he just rolled his eyes so for those who
don't know
Aubrey de Grey is a chief science
officer at Sens Research Foundation and
you are also recently now the vp of new
tech discovery at Ajax therapeutics a
little under a year previously I
Methuselah foundation and PhD in biology
from Cambridge so a little bit of
background by Aubrey Aubrey cares about
helping people stay healthy forever
that's perfectly well and getting giving
them at least the choice to stay healthy
forever well yeah I mean realistically
there is no difference of opinion there
I have never met anyone who wants to get
Alzheimer's I want anybody else to get
out famine yep so didn't you taught me
this as well which was that metabolism
causes pathology right I mean aging all
that all that is is a you know
highfalutin way of saying that aging is
a side effect of being alive yes
metabolism is the word that biologists
use to encompass the entire network of
stuff that the body does to keep us
going from one day to the next and it
creates damage throughout life changes
at the molecular and cellular level to
the composition and structure of our
various tissues and organs and that's
basically harmless for a long time
because the body is set up to tolerate
it but the body is only set up to
tolerate a certain amount of that damage
so eventually it does to impaired mental
and physical performance and eventually
we die yep
so so being aging as a byproduct of
being alive and the longer that you live
the more you age and therefore the more
you get disease now about staying
healthy we've talked about homeostatic
capacity before with genuine homeostasis
so this body's ability to return to
equilibrium when we're a child it's much
more easy for our body to rejuvenate and
get back to equilibrium when we're older
it's harder there's a decent amount of
staying healthy forever have to do with
the homeostatic capacity really yes
really homeostatic capacity is a good
way of measuring how healthy you are and
in particular of measuring how much of
this aging damage you have accumulated
because the aging damage before it
starts to result in clear deficiencies
of function into the things that we call
division even though we really shouldn't
call the disease because that parts of
Aging
before that happens still there is an
effect a lower level effect on systems
of homeostasis
well something says mean it's everything
that we do to restore health when health
is impeded in a cute way by an infection
or by an injury you know wound healing
is slower in older people than it is in
younger people that's an example
fighting off of infection is slower this
is all aspects of homeostatic capacity
and the reason these things are slower
is because the machinery to to restore
that homeostasis is there but it is
somehow handicapped increasingly by the
damage that's lying around getting in
its way this is this is crazy the the GI
tract is the only from the mouth through
your anus is the only
open part of your body the only part of
your body that's open to the air the
whole through the well I mean I guess
you would kind of your lungs but yeah
where you guys with that there you go in
your lungs yeah I just learned that
really like really kind of made that
part of my understanding yesterday just
because the the gut has more BEC more
bacterial cells in your body than human
cells
lots more bacterial cells are a lot
smaller than human cells you think and
then there's so much to do with do they
actually have a lot to do with our
pathology a smaller disease mm-hmm there
is a lot of linkage but it's probably
not in my view at the moment anyway it's
probably not a linkage that we need to
be paying all that much attention to now
I want to be cautious about this because
there's a lot of isn't known and
certainly we are finding out a lot or
every day about how the microbiome
especially the gut microbiome interacts
with the body and there are a whole
companies being built around this in
fact I'm advising one of them cuz I am I
was going to talk about that cool huh
Naveen was just on or okay but here's
the thing in aging what you tend to see
is damage accumulating in parts of the
body organs and tissues that are not
being recycled very much and you know
whether there's no cell for example
cells that are not dividing so they're
just sitting there long lived sitting
there not dividing like brain cells
muscle cells heart cells those cells
tend to accumulate damage more rapidly
than cells that are regularly dividing
now the microbiome since it's made of
bacteria is consisting of cells that are
dividing so for that reason it's a lot
more you know versatile it's a lot more
malleable
I feel therefore that by and large what
we're going to see is that as we
continue to get better at fixing up the
parts of the body that are made of human
cells and that don't turn over very much
so the microbiome insofar as it changes
during aging will spontaneously
rejuvenates
and we won't have to actually directly
call the rejuvenation of the microbiome
to occur and then is the cells that are
not dividing that are communicating
they're causing aging are those cells
are causing disease are those kind of
one of the big targets of sense OSHA I
mean the way that we normally describe
the list of targets a sense it's not by
dividing it according to which type of
cell is involved because that just gets
unnecessarily complicated but the way we
do divide it into different types of
molecular damage and cellular damage we
tend to see those types of damage
accumulating to a greater degree in
non-dividing cells than in regularly
dividing cells yep there are exceptions
so a key exception is cancer cancer
clearly the disease of excessive cell
division so cells that are
constitutively unable to divide like
heart cells for example they can't
become cancerous right they you know
they're definitely able to but that's
forcing the cells don't divide so
they're there for the camp of cancerous
right but that's kind of an exception
most of the types of damage that we are
looking at that happen inside cells once
that will generally be less prevalent
less important in dividing cells because
they will be easier for the body
spontaneously to control so with how are
we aiming to restore the body's ability
to function kind of around the age of
whatever 13 or 18 when it's kind of at
its peak are we trying to keep that
forever we are exactly we're trying to
maintain the function of the body as it
is in adolescence or early adulthood and
the way we're going to do that is by
maintaining the structure of the body in
that form so if we look at the various
types of molecular and cellular change
that occur progressively occurred during
life if we can simply reverse those
things not reverse the processes that
cause them but actually simply repair
the damage so take things back to how
that
then we're done basically if since the
human body is after all just a machine
albeit a really really complicated one
we can be sure that if we restore its
structure then we will also restore its
function then you tell me about the the
car analogy that's a good one all right
yeah I mean I think this is very
important it's very very important in
terms of raising awareness and generally
improving people's understanding of
Aging and about what we can do about it
it's very important to get people out of
the mindset of thinking that aging is
some kind of mystery some kind of enigma
it is it just isn't and the best way I
found to do that is to point out that
aging is not really a particularly
biology specific phenomena that the
nature of Aging in living organisms it's
really no different at its root than
aging of inanimate machines like cars or
airplanes it's not like so I mean there
are of course other phenomena which are
what you might call emergent aspects of
biology consciousness you know rocks
cars airplanes do not have consciousness
we can be very sure of that but aging is
not one of those things
now this is this is a likely a very
frequent point of contention for you a
lot of people tend to drop this one on
you but why not die why not embrace
death yeah I mean so I see the mindset
of people who ask that question as a
mindset of desperation because the thing
is when people ask this question
generally I've already told them hello
it's not about death it's not about
death at all it's about house
and they never come back to me and say
yeah why embrace house no they're
already embracing house and they're
perfectly happy to do so they just don't
want to hear that this longevity thing
is simply a side effect right simply a
natural consequence of staying healthy
because they don't want to be faced with
what they see is this dichotomy is this
contradiction where they know that they
want to be healthy but they don't know
they want to be long live yes yes that
seems to be what the case is that so
okay then now if I'm given the choice of
staying healthy then then at any point I
can choose to die well anyone can walk
in front of a truck I mean you know
we've got a word for that we call it
suicide right and of course it's suicide
if you do it slowly to you know if you
choose not to avail yourself of medical
technology that's available to you yeah
you know that's your choice but chances
are we're going to try and change your
mind same as we you know we have suicide
hotlines for a reason the most people
are fairly happy that we do okay so my
the way that my body currently even half
of the age of my body really when I was
younger was able to be in its peak state
of health what would you say is like the
number one way to retain that peak state
of health until you're 25 45 55 Oh give
me large amounts of money
I mean honestly yeah there is nothing
that we can do with today's men
the only things that we have today are
things that if existed since the dawn of
time and that we've all known like Doug
gets seriously overweight don't get
don't smoke you know have a reasonably
balanced diet so that you're reasonably
sure to be not short of any
micronutrients all those kinds of
obvious things work but that's it you
know everything else people make such a
fuss about today different particular
diet or lifestyle or anything like some
minut difference to how long a given
person is going to be able to stay
healthy and therefore stay alive
therefore we need stuff that simply
doesn't exist yet we need better
medicine which is what we've got it what
I'm working on
and unfortunately the development of
those medicines take serious money yes
and then it's a medicine well yeah I
mean of course you may work well with
the terminology there are small molecule
drugs there are stem cells or organ
transplants or I mean a therapies
they're all medicines at once but out of
those four which one would you say it's
kind of the biggest player oh there
isn't one package together I mean of
course as time goes on this might change
somewhat in terms of emphasis for
example transplant organs is just a lot
of organs is a very invasive type of
medicine which is not compatible with
serious health people are a desk drawer
and not terribly good at having heart
surgery right um so we want to find that
out quickly as possible we want to be
able to do everything that we want might
need to do with organ transplantation in
less invasive ways using stem cells or
whatever so it's a today doe does
somebody that has access to a couple
million or even a billion dollars what
can they buy to stay healthier well
again it's a kind of you know if that
particular person is prioritizing their
own health rather than what I do would
yes I or I think everybody health yes
then first of all I think I've done
because the fact is the difference that
one can make
by either dedicating one's career to
this the way I have or dedicating one's
fortune to this the way that some people
might and then whether I did in fact as
well of course as we know you know
whatever you do you're only going to
affect the date at which aging is
defeated by medicine you know by a few
years right at most and that's only
going to affect your own personal
chances by a few percent depending on
exactly how old you are right so it's
really not a clever way to think
mathematically you know I think what
gets me out of bed in the morning it's
not that I'm you know improving my own
chances or I have improve my own chances
but I don't even money is a right
whereas I'm saving a hundred thousand
lives for every day that I bring forward
the defeat of aging you know which is
quite easy to get out of bed for so
that's the way people ought to say
100,000 people die per day due to aging
hundred and ten thousand that's right
yeah well that's more than two-thirds of
all deaths worldwide yes so I mean so
any wealthy individual especially any
wealthy technophile who basically gets
this I say you know first of all think
in humanitarian ways not so much in
personal way yeah well if you insist on
thinking in personal waves then still
it's all about hastening the development
of therapies that don't yet exist and
therefore improving your own chances of
benefiting from those therapies rather
than spending money on therapies that
already exist but don't work
yeah that collective mindset is one that
usually drives people towards wanting to
solve this same thing with the onset of
Alzheimer's and other heart disease etc
that that cancer that drives people to
to not want to suffer in those ways not
want to see their family suffer
themselves suffer hmm
so the this is this is still so MC
listed immunotherapy you listed organ
transplant you listed what other ways
will stem-cell therapy everything that
we are currently using in medicine in
general for early onset yeah things that
affect people early in life applied also
applies also to the alcohol age you know
these are just delivery technologies the
the difference between medicine for
age-related problems and medicine
early life problems is in the level of
details of exactly what themselves we
deliver or what gene therapy different
stem cell therapies and gene therapies
are delivered at later years than
younger years what would be I guess a
stem cell therapy or gene therapy for
the younger years too so I mean people
use stem cell therapies in childhood
diseases to fix things like you know
sickle cell anemia you know these people
stem cells that correct or compensate
for genetic deficiencies that affect
people early in life whereas in late
life we're looking at repairing
progressive chronic damage for example
Parkinson's disease is a great example
there are a number of clinical trials in
progress or a or being cited up right
now with regards to Parkinson's disease
and that's a classic very obvious
example of an aspect of aging which is
appropriate to treat him that way
because it revolves around the loss of a
particular type of cell called
dopaminergic neuron which is present in
a particular part of the brain
dopaminergic neurons have a very very
high energy utilization and that means
they damage themselves quickly and that
means that they die quickly which means
that we all of us have lost maybe a
quarter of our dopaminergic neurons by
old age a quarter is okay the system is
set up to tolerate that amount of love
but some people little bit further and
they've lost maybe three quarters in the
system is not set up to tolerate that so
that's why people get Parkinson's take
us into the molecular and the and the
cellular level in with understanding
what is exactly going to come in there
and to do the repair so that question
let's start from what I just said about
Parkinson's so what's going on there
you've got a lot be brought cells in a
particular part of the brain it's called
the substantia [ __ ] and they die and
when they were there they used to create
this thing called dopamine definitely is
a very important kind of chemical in the
brain and it needs to be transmitted
around the brain and these neurons do
that when they die you've got less
dopamine being made you've got their
stuff meaning being distributed so if we
can inject cells into the brain which
are not actually dopaminergic neurons
themselves there are precursors which
have been set up epigenetically in a way
so that they know what to do so they
will divide and that the daughter cells
will transform into dopaminergic neurons
that provides a kind of constant supply
then you know you've got your documents
back you've got you dumping me back
you've got your functions back if
Parkinson goes away so some take out the
dead you know just the detritus of the
dead cells is already spontaneously
eliminated you definitely replace them
and then do they need to be replaced in
the specific position not exactly
so if you put them in more or less the
right position in this one single part
of the brain which is morphologically
distinguishable you know if not I'm not
a tiny tiny PI it's big enough that you
can see it right then that's good enough
what part of the brain it's called the
substantia [ __ ] substantial diagram
mm-hmm front back so just like that were
adding dopaminergic stem cells them in
the very early nascent stage and then
we're putting them in this specific area
and then from there we've done these
tests with mice what
that actually so the first time that
this kind of thing was tried was more
than was about 25 years ago in Sweden
and back then they already saw that this
was the obvious way to treat Parkinson's
disease but what they didn't have was a
sophisticated ability to manipulate stem
cells in the laboratory before injecting
them so it was very hit and miss what
they ended up injecting so if they got
lucky they would inject some
dopaminergic precursor cells but in
general you know there was going to be a
lot of other stuff that would not make
their from you know sick neurons and
sure enough nearly all of the people
that were treated had no benefit only a
few of them had a benefit and in fact
when the same kind of thing with
attempted in the US by a couple of other
groups shortly afterwards
they didn't get any successes so
everyone more or less gave up on it back
then but the only reason why they gave
up was because they didn't have this
ability to specifically generate
neuronal precursors of the right type
because if you went back to the Swedish
trial the original trial there were a
few successes as I said and those
successes were not just any old
successes they were unbelievable what
happened was that the people were
completely freed of parkinsonian
symptoms they were already on the
standard of care a chemical called
l-dopa which you can inject which is a
precursor of this dopamine so it kind of
compensate for the absence of
spontaneous dopamine synthesis but it
doesn't do very well after a couple of
years they were taken off the old route
but they didn't need it anymore because
their stem cells were doing the job
right they're new then you neurons were
doing the job and there was a paper
published just 18 months ago I say which
was to celebrate the 25th anniversary of
the first successful responder who is
still alive and has had no parkinsonian
symptoms ever since one injection of
these stem cells no l-dopa no anything
else
no parkinsonism so now you know I mean
this is just an illustration of course
but basically the cost of the climate of
opinion in the expert community is very
positive and
we've got quite a few groups around the
world working on new trials they're kind
of a contortion that's actually you know
getting that going and everyone's very
very gung-ho what was the method of
injection then and what is it now that's
not really changed very much you know
injection is injection of course you can
change this kind of thing if you're
talking about the brain then you can't
do what you would normally do with with
stem cell therapy for the rest of the
body which is just inject them into the
bloodstream and let them find their home
because as this thing called the
blood-brain barrier that gets in the way
he should he's just a bit about that
quick
okay the blood-brain barrier is a
special kind of way in which the cells
of the blood vessels in the brain linked
together they link together rather more
tightly than cells in that that are the
boundary of the vasculature and the rest
of the body and that means that
molecules themselves giving which would
normally be able to get through from the
bloodstream into the the into organs and
tissues can't do so in the brain um so
the simple way to get around that is
just to inject directly into the you
know beyond that barrier into another
kind of place called the cerebrospinal
fluid which is they kind of the
circulatory system of the brain itself
and you go through the neck you can glue
it that way yes but that's actually not
so not so effective either but that's
how it passes that that's cool well the
city the CSF the cerebral spinal fluid
is very sticky
it's very viscous and that means the
things don't flow around it very well
another group that I'm very interested
working very interested in in the New
York actually the Apennine Star College
of Medicine is looking at trying to
solve that problem in pox disease you're
not really worried about this because
you can inject directly into the correct
part of the brand of substantia [ __ ]
but there are other types of brain aging
especially Alzheimer's disease in which
the damage the loss of cells that we
need to fix is much more widespread and
so if you just inject a bolus of cells
into one spot
it's not gonna really do much good you
need to have them to actively migrate
despite the fact that they fluid within
which they are migrating it's very
viscous could we equip them with some of
the skills that the t-cell has to go and
detect those location well more or less
got the right idea in this case it's not
exactly that we want to have them target
sites of damage the way that you might
see in the in the rest of the body
though that would help the main thing is
you want them to target anywhere if they
could just just distribute themselves
randomly that would still be a great
deal better than not distributing
overtalk right and that's something that
some cells in the brain already do the
type of immune cell called the microglia
which is a bit like a macrophage
and it already knows how to actively
migrate and so this may be a clip the
one that actually know some migrates
called the microglia microglia and
there's and it's just an it just
randomly migration is a random okay in
the current injection for Parkinson's is
what what how does it actually get there
through cerebral spinal oh well no no no
you inject directly into the correct
part of the brain they the substantial
not the what's the tool that is used I
have no I don't know okay
for whatever do you what are you
thinking yeah
yeah I love thinking about all the
different unique attributes that the
different cells and the different parts
of the body have and then trying to
figure out how to manifest that golden
key to this problem but there is no
golden key I thought well golden key
that's for sure I also really love just
thinking about having the homeostatic
capacity just my body at its full prime
throughout the rest is let's let's chat
about this briefly if we are living
until 100 150 and even though
populations do stabilize once they
become developed does that then increase
population on the planet relation will
probably increase increases rather
slowly though if and if you take into
account if you don't take it to account
the reduction for 30 rates and therefore
we really need to worry about it because
what matters is not the actual absolute
number of people on the planet what
matters is the amount of damage that the
average person does to the planet by way
of pollution and a song goes on of
course what we're doing it's about in
cleaner technologies whether it's
renewable energy or artificial meats or
you know desalination all of these
things are allowing us to have more
people on the planet they're increasing
the carrying capacity of the planet if
you like and that's gonna happen it's no
question that's definitely going to
happen much faster than any increase in
the actual population of the planet in
the other seeable future okay okay so
clean technologies are as long as we get
that straight and the amount of people
will just slowly slowly increase of
course the big thing that we have to
remember is that we don't have to rely
on good well or conscientiousness or
responsibility of society here you know
people have been saying since forever oh
god we need to worry about climate
change we need to use more renewable and
because otherwise everyone's gonna be
underwater I didn't really work but now
what we're saying is that renewable
energy is exploding for a completely
different much more boring mercenary
reason namely people have figured out
how to make it more cheaply than fossil
filled mm-hmm it is is that a direct
reference to like solar and wind you
know even wave energy you know these
things we're all going sheep a seller in
winter of course leading the way but
it's not just renewable energy of course
I mean we all know the climate changes
also very strongly affected by
agriculture you know by by cows and so
on and you know that's why artificial
meat matters yeah you know and again I
think assume it's gonna be just a safety
it's gonna be cheaper
we had posture on the show and Josh
Tetrick they were both pioneering the
industry we love that aspect of biotech
so much a lot a lot of the questions
that we asked in October were
interestingly more in the developmental
stages of the kind of the show and now
we have a set of questions that are a
little bit different I wonder if maybe
maybe we should talk before we get to
some of the other points about this this
is let's let's mention this guy I think
this is really important to the audience
the fact that you guys got about before
how much was a six and a half million
dollars in crypto donations to cents
Research Foundation in one in one year
one month in one month yet between
mid-december and mid-january Jeff got
and now was that because of something
related there see see that enable no no
I mean of course it was fundamentally
right to the fact that the previous
month and two months cryptocurrency is
all
through the ceiling yeah so you know a
number of people much wealthier than
they had expected to be but I think the
key thing to learn from this is not just
that it is the people who donated I mean
we don't know injecting most games who
they even were but it looks like the
people who doing he were very much the
younger generation people in their
twenties and this is a massive thing for
me because I have always wondered why
there are not more people donating who
have wealth and you understand
technology and the value of all of this
um and I'm going to see that even though
technophiles wealthy technophile
especially they talk a good talk
nevertheless at the back of their minds
they still got Muslim anyway the same
kind of hangups the same kinds of
irrational priorities that less wealthy
people have and the young generation in
increasing numbers and not like that
they've grown up knowing that aging is a
really bad thing and B is potentially
amenable to medical intervention they
haven't had to reject anything that they
were taught of kid no Vitaliy booster in
our biggest donor who of course was the
founder of aetherium he actually told me
that he's been a fan of my work since he
was a teenager he read my book when he
was like 14
right and so you know these are the
children of the revelation people who
product of the culture the mindset the
understanding that I've been trying to
generate over the years do you do you
think that the Millennials and the Gen
see do you think that they have more of
a you were mentioning how it's a more of
a humanitarian mindset that's usually
you try and help people understand about
about aging and age-related disease and
death do you think that maybe the
Millennials and Gen Z kind of has
somewhat of a globalised or a collective
mindset approach to things out
no a theology a thorough psychologist so
I don't really want to get too specific
about what's really going on in the
heads of these people all I really know
is what they tell me and that was a good
example of italic is that's a people
it's funny you mention it he's putting
his money where his mouth is about it
and when other people will talk to talk
but then they won't walk the walk that's
uh that's indicative of a lie and what
are you doing anyway why you
what's the reason have a third boat I
don't need a third boat why not and why
not invest into 50 people solving a
problem give them enough room to do it
for another year two years yep so
operating budgets about four to five
million a year that's what it's been for
quite some time now yes it costs you
that much money to run to run the
minimal rate that we're going now we
could totally add another zero to that
and we would have no trouble knowing
what to spend it not only want to spend
it on and what is the staff well very
few of course you know in Mountain View
and I headquarters we have maybe fifteen
people mostly scientists if you admin
people we keep it very lean with very
very efficient the additional
expenditure is on PhD students and
postdoctoral fellows in various
universities and institutes in labs that
we support today other important work
the scientists that sends what would be
some of the things that they're doing
well the number one most the biggest
project that we have there is working on
mitochondrial mutations we're interested
in the fact that the mitochondrion is a
really bad place for DNA to be there's
not much DNA there but the DNA that if
they're in code thirteen essential
proteins and sure enough that DNA
accumulates damage much much faster than
anger you're growing really fast I want
to make sure I'm keeping up so
mitochondria the pot the power generator
in every cell that's right the other
place where the chemistry of breathing
happens where oxygen is combined with
nutrients to extract energy from those
nutrients and that they do this using a
very very mmm you know Heath Robinson
like approach to
the chemistry that's very efficient but
it only evolved once and it's a real
mess and it is prone to having side
effects it makes free radicals which of
course toxic molecules let's let's
unpack that just a little bit more okay
so so the inhalation of oxygen and then
the carrying of the oxygen by the red
blood cells that book okay okay to the
rest of the body that's right and then
when it gets dumped self brings back the
carbon dioxide okay and then the
powerhouse of the cell it releases a
free radical array these chemicals
called free radicals that's right which
are toxic and that is just the process
of metabolism that is a kind of
accidental byproduct of what the
mitochondrion is supposed to do which is
to combine oxygen in a safe way in a
harmless non-toxic way with nutrients so
as to extract energy and covered up main
byproduct of that it's harmless and
that's why we breathe it out but at a
low but still dangerous level there the
other buckle that's called free radicals
and in that builds up in the South the
free radicals themselves do not build on
that they do damage they react the
chemical react with DNA for example and
with proteins and thought and the damage
that that constitutes that built that so
so to envision a free radical was that
at the atomic level oh yeah yeah it's
more molecular okay okay and then that
way so that molecule then is does
interacts
chemically with DNA and proteins to do
things like what unravel the telomeres
oh yeah oh yeah that can happen break to
them is off you know called mutations
where base pair tell you to do something
else because you know
link cross-linking of proteins so that
they can't be degraded and destroyed the
way they should be things like that and
then the scientists are looking at the
mitochondria for the free radicals so
it's a little complicated so
mitochondria accumulate damage but
mitochondria are also recycled quite
rapidly so the damage that the
mitochondria most of the damage that the
mitochondria have does not actually
accumulate it's repaired while it's
eliminated as fast as it's created some
of that damage especially cross-linking
of proteins that I mentioned is not
capable of being repaired and eliminated
and that accumulates slowly in a
different part of the cell called the
lysosome um but the damage that we're
working on in Mountainview is not that
there's a bunch of those lysosomes right
now service there are a bunch of
mitochondria and then what are those
again with the garbage disposal
it's an incinerator basically yeah it's
the place where stuff gets broken down
but there are some things that even the
incinerator cannot break down they
accumulate within the lysosome all right
so um what can you have their own DNA
not very much but it's very important
and only from the mother that's true yes
and here's the important thing when
mitochondria have this recycling you
know where some of them are destroyed
the way that new mitochondria are
generated is by replicating an old one
now in order to do that you introduce
new completely undamaged proteins and
lipids and so on but the DNA of course
is created by DNA replication same as
the DNA in the nucleus is replicated
when a cell divides right which means
that if the DNA has already been mutated
and then the mutation is going to
propagate right so in the end it turns
out that what happens in aging if that
cells get taken over completely by
mutant mitochondrial DNA and not many
self get taken over in this way but the
ones that do seem to be very bad for us
and
yeah we gonna fix them oh we've got to
somehow get rid of them
mutant mitochondrial DNA driving now the
way that we are trying to do this is an
idea that was first put forward in the
mid-eighties way before I came along
which is to put backup copies of that
DNA into the nucleus if we take a gene
from the mitochondrial DNA
then there are certain fairly obvious
ways in which we might be able to modify
that gene so that we could put it in the
nucleus and it would still work even
though the genes in the wrong place
it would have to you know create the
protein that it's supposed to create and
then that project would have to be
imported into the mitochondria from
outside know that not nearly as hard as
it sounds because a huge number of human
more than a thousand proteins already
are important in this way and the
mitochondrial DNA only encodes another
13 protein so it's just like co-opting
that existing machinery but it turns out
of course that the devil is in the
detail and people have tried to do this
for a long time and they gave up and we
didn't give up and we're going to work
now more or less the process of getting
rid of the mutant mitochondrial gene we
don't actually get rid of the mutant
mitochondrial DNA what we do is we make
that mutant mitochondrial DNA harmless
by putting new DNA in the nucleus that
creates the same proteins so that even
if the mitochondrial DNA is broken the
mitochondria themselves still work
because they've still got the right
protein in an assault does not dot
correct and in particular the Feld have
not become toxic okay and then then then
the mutant mitochondrial DNA just lives
inside of the lysosomes no the mutant
mitochondrial DNA lives inside the
mitochondria yeah but they repaired back
up mitochondrial DNA lives in the
nucleus yes I'm still that way it
doesn't so the damage the other type of
damage I was talking about where
cross-linked proteins and so on can't be
broken down that still happens and we
need to fix that in a different way but
this is won't the mutant may control DNA
keep building up in the mitochondria and
then that still causes disease or not
the mutant
country would not cause disease anymore
because the mutation wouldn't matter
anymore the D and they would be
superfluous that whether it's me they
don't know matter and that's the number
one thing that they're studying right
that's the biggest project that we have
at the lab we have other projects
they're just as big being worked on
elsewhere in other universities and
Institute's and what's one of the big
ones there um well let's see we've got a
big project at Yale which is focused on
cross-linking in the spaces between
cells so one thing that people often
forget is that the way the body holds
together is not just because of our
skeleton that's not why I wear that
shape we are it's also because of the
physical properties of various tissues
in particular various tissues need to be
elastic in order to work well a great
example would be the major arteries so
they have to be elastic in order to kind
of buffer the pulsation from the
heartbeat so those to protect the more
fragile parts of the second system the
capillaries and when we get older the
the major arteries become less elastic
the result of that is that blood have to
go up basically the heart has to pump
faster in order to get the blow around
and the capillaries don't like that you
know high blood pressure is bad for you
right so we want to restore elasticity
of the arteries and also elsewhere in
the body for example in the skin the
reason why we get wrinkles is because of
the same chemical process that's the
loss of elasticity of proteins that are
giving the tissue the RCC it used to
have now the chemical basis for this has
been quite well understood for a long
time we know that sugar in the
bloodstream reacts very occasionally but
often enough with the proteins that are
holding the tissues together these
proteins are called the extracellular
matrix and this reaction with sugars
causes that matrix to become more
disordered and less elastic so we want
to
restore it now in principle one could do
that by simply breaking down the
extracellular matrix and getting the
cells to make new stuff but that turns
out to be pretty hard and you know it's
got side effects so instead what we want
to do is simply rejuvenate the existing
extracellular matrix by eliminating the
chemical modifications that these
reactions with sugar have caused and
that's not all that hard in principle
because the chemical modifications are
very weird the chemical structures that
result from this thing that will have
all the cross-links the chemical
structures are just very different from
anything that the body makes on purpose
for any physiological rock that function
so in principle one should be able to
get generate drugs that would be able to
break these cross-links and thereby
restoring our city without having side
effects because they had other other
reactions elsewhere in the body and um
you know it's a lot easier said than
done again if this is an area where a
lot of people knew what to do a long
time ago but they gave up because it was
too hard we were in elasticity and we
persevered and it worked out the group
at Yale were able to find ways to move
forward in this at the moment we're not
so much looking for drugs that will
break these cross-links working for
enzymes that do it and we seem to have
found some and actually the group there
have made enough progress now that not
only did we have a very high-profile
publication in science magazine a couple
of years ago reporting the first
breakthrough here but also you know
people have got interested in creating a
company here so we've got investors who
are not just interested in philanthropic
support of this but actually and making
money out of it and that company is
about to come into existence that will
be actually number six so we've already
created five companies as in one way or
another spin out from the work that
we've been doing
and we regard that really as you know a
fundamental definition of our business
strategy it were a nonprofit of course
if either one C 3 public charity but our
goal is to be the engine room of the
industry to actually move these very
very challenging high-risk high-reward
project far enough along in the
proof-of-concept process so that at
least the more visionary type of
investor had willing to go in this
high-risk high-reward way will be will
be interested in getting involved in
especially with the business like
restoring elasticity that that seems
attractive for markets like Los Angeles
totally absolutely I mean certainly we
would expect that the L group will focus
into the products must in the short term
on the skin even though of course our
main goal in terms of serious ill health
in old age will be the vasculature yeah
yep and what are some of the other ones
that spun out as companies well I guess
the single most successful oneself I
mean they will be very successful but
the thing most accessible ones if I
probably I call I see hor so I call it's
basically in upstate New York and they
are focused on macular degeneration this
one I'm so happy I learned about that
when I was younger because now I
actually at least have a decent
understanding of it very very elementary
school level but this is what happens
when you have someone like Aubrey that
sits across from you and just goes this
this this this this this this and you
finally are like oh at least I know
something a little bit about that one
right so my kids generation we've got
it's the number one cause of blindness
in the elderly and the ways in which
people have so far been trying to treat
it have not been terribly effective
probably the most exciting and most
promising approach that's being pursued
recently it's themselves because what
happens in macular degeneration is it
cells in the back of the eye just die
and they're not replaced and therefore
the eye stops being able to see but stem
cell therapy for on the nerve is it on
the nerve are on that
it's different it's not the nerve cells
themselves it sells the connector than
ourselves in the back of the retina so
the stem cell therapies that have been
tried have been somewhat effective but
they haven't really taken the world by
storm and a big part of the reason is
that it turns out there are two types of
cell that you need to replace in order
to fix macular degeneration there are
the photoreceptor cells the rods and
cones which are the cells that actually
absorb light and do that if you like the
chemistry of vision right called retinal
pigmented epithelial cells which are
kind of support cells behind them those
are the cells that die first
as a result of accumulating a waste
product called this retinoid which is a
kind of byproduct of vitamin A and the
photoreceptor cells die as a result of
no longer having the support of the
support cells so we want to intervene a
little earlier than that we want to
simply rescue the RPE cells the retinal
pigmented epithelial cells by giving
them the ability to break down this
toxic byproduct of vitamin A that I
mentioned and we worked on this for
several years we got a bit stuck
actually we had a bit of a brick wall
but we handed over the technology to
some people who to the sky Kelsey Moody
who used to work for us for several
years and he wants to start this company
and he was able to crack it basically he
made a team were able to identify a
couple of key breakthroughs that we had
not been able to achieve the result is
they've got something that seems to
really work and expected to be in
clinical trials within a year and
they've been able to write reasonably
proper money you know I think that up
there in the ten million or so range now
they've been able to write all the money
they needed to get this stuff done which
is you know a fantastic first time I
heard about macular degeneration was
from an augmented reality company that
was helping people see after not being
able to see and that so how many people
saw is are the people so they've raised
ten you said okay and they've helped a
couple thousand people with it or no no
it's going in clinical trial
the next year or so father work is only
preclinical and the volumize but it's
good but it works in mice it's good
enough to be able to for them to be able
to write this kind of money how do we
know if we're fixing macular
degeneration oh that's pretty easy you
can definitely tell whether I might not
be saying stuff yeah even though we
don't have a direct camera of what
they're seeing you can tell that they
don't bump into the walls and that they
can get to the destination for that
correct yeah okay so that's a couple of
the companies good I'm glad that it's
getting the attention that deserves
especially this last donation that's not
oh yeah and it seemed it seems like
that's the direction like I really I
really do think that people that are
young are gonna end up being more
involved in making the world a better
place and and I think that eventually
more people will snap out of the Pro
aging trance I think so
looks like well thank you for leading
thank you for leading and getting me
into this as well
every dude let's let's wandering you
down a couple unless you think is there
some is there another thought that I
that you think would be really good to
share on the program while you're here I
think you're covering the main themes
you know I think what we're trying to
draw out here is the fact that number
one the actual research is going really
well
it's going progressively faster as we
make more progress and there's more
money comes in however on the other side
emphasizing the fact that there still
isn't nearly enough money in all of this
whether coming to the foundation or to
companies that we've spawned or to other
companies and growing up in parallel
with us now everyone needs much more
funding in order to be able to make the
rate-limiting step being what it ought
to be name is a simple difficulty of the
science our school calico doing some
talk to me about calico
what's calico is an absolute
embarrassment it was spectacular
catastrophe solely crap I did not think
you were in a city so of course calico
started out being a fantastic benefit to
the mission simply by coming in to exist
you know if people with the credibility
of Larry and Sergey are going to put
proper money behind this then it's not a
part cream it's not science fiction
anymore but unfortunately they did it in
the worst possible way first of all they
decided that they wanted to do it as a
business rather than as a research
organization but then they decided to
make it functionally a research
organization by not putting any
timeframe on it right what they ended up
doing was with the company becoming a
kind of schizophrenic like having its
own internal valley of death well you've
got in calico is a CEO who is probably
the world's best biotech CEO here at
Genentech for a long time you know he's
amazing he knows how to run a biotech
company that has products but almost had
products he doesn't know anything about
how to feed aging now he knows that he
doesn't know anything about her defeat
aging unfortunately he also doesn't know
who to hire so what he actually did he
went out and hired a chief science
officer who was the worst possible
person you could get not only did this
person not know anything about aging but
he also his name's David Botstein he
also was a really really good basic
scientist now I use that word kind of
prejudicially basic scientists are great
in their place but if you want someone
to fix a humanitarian problem here they
are the worst people to go to the last
people you should go to because they do
not care about fixing problems they care
about finding things out and they never
know when they have found out enough to
be able to fix a problem because for a
basic scientist there is no such thing
as having found out enough the purpose
of finding things out in itself the
purpose so Calico are simply a
researcher what I mean on the one hand
one part of calico is Genentech mark two
harmless but useless to the
mission the other half of calico is NIH
part two you know it is just completely
duplicating what would be done anyway
with you know another chunk of money
it's unbelievable that they would not
understand that the important thing to
do is to have people who understand how
to be a techno there have been goal
directed approach but at the same time
understand how to work on really hard
problems you know Larry met me first
in 2005 Sergey that we first in 2003
they have no excuse it's an absolute
catastrophe damn that's so unfortunate
to hear that that happened I did was not
anywhere near aware of that what does it
doesn't it seem like common sense though
to have these higher people in aging
that well I mean in fairness they've
hired really good people in ancient you
know the first person I heard he was a
card-carrying gerontologist was Cynthia
Kenyon who is a scientist for whom I
have enormous respect and furthermore
she's a scientist who is fearless when
it comes to going out and saying that
the that the imperative to actually do
something about anything rather than
just understand it is profound she was
doing that in the early 1990s ten years
before I came along you know and she was
doing it from a position of much greater
vulnerability than me as well she was
she didn't even have tenure back then so
you know I have I totally had tough
dicta Cynthia but she was a black sheep
a little bit whoa she was a very smart
and very she has a particular idea about
how to defeat aging she lived here oh
yeah she was at UCSF many many years and
now she's a calico quote don't be
greater potentially a version well yeah
good luck with that but the thing about
Cynthia is see how the particular idea
about how to defeat aging it's totally
not going to work well because
it's based on a phenomenon that simply
doesn't scale with species lifespan it's
a phenomenon that she pioneered the
understanding of in very short lived
organisms that live normally a month or
less and it have a really big effect
they already had a significant but much
smaller effect in mice and it had
virtually zero affected in chimpanzees
and not in monkeys and and you know not
the way to go but she's wedded to it
what was that well basically it's
emulating famine it's essentially
tricking the body into thinking it's in
a family in one way or another so that
it organizes its metabolic priorities
accordingly it was a great way to extend
the lifespan of short lived or it
doesn't work in yeah yeah um so that's
that's one you know appalling take yeah
right researcher totally the wrong
person for this job though the other
people they've hired other good
gerontologist like Shelley Buffon's Dean
for example again fantastic scientists
undoubtedly going to do really important
work to help us understand aging much
better but we don't need to understand
aging much better what we need to do
with you is what we already know yeah
and fund what we already know yeah yeah
I'm just curious if is there anything
that the sentence foundation yeah
learns through progeria the rapid
accelerated models of a whether in
humans or in Mulligan's like mice have
always been very you know popular and
and you know heavy areas of study and of
course they can teach us some things but
actually everyone's known for a long
long time that there's plenty that they
can't teach us because pretty much into
pretty much universally these models
accelerate one particular mechanism of
damage accumulation and the accelerated
huge amount like all of the magnitude
which one which one well it depends on
the on the model so in the gate approach
area it's you know
and the nucleus this damage kind of
feeds out it kind of spreads out and you
know affect other processes so you get
other types of damage accumulating
somewhat faster than normal so you end
up in a situation where quite often a
lot of the things that go wrong with
people late in life all go wrong
simultaneously much earlier in life but
that's still the fact still remains that
you did this by fixing by breaking one
particular thing right doing was mutant
or whatever no that means that fixing it
is also fixing just one thing it all
fans out from that thing and you're not
going to really learn anything by
successfully fixing that one thing about
the situation in normal aging where
everything's going on for independent or
at least interacting reasons but not for
one root cause that's the fundamental
difficulty is was there something when
we were initially chatting before the
show when you mentioned that the lower
level of in the kingdom like a reptiles
amphibians do you what trait they have
in order to right so my second job that
I took not long ago at Ajax which is the
new subsidiary of biotin of my quest
created is largely focused on this
question of the regenerative capacity
that exists both in lower vertebrates
like salamanders and so on and also in
mammals early on in their development
there's a transition that occurs it's a
very poorly understood and poorly
studied transition which were calling
the embryonic fatal transition in which
and it's kind of semi depressed semi
related but somewhat independent from
the differentiation process that of
course is occurring in the protein in
the building of the of the organism
during that period what happens is that
the regenerative capacity just changes
when a wound happens before this
transition then the wound just goes away
the you know cells divide and the tissue
is remodeled and everything you wouldn't
know you'd have the entry after the
injury it's not the same you get scar
tissue things like that if we and of
course it's not just scar tissue this
can
a more diffuse way so if you embryonic
when a preface or pre-pre fetal yeah
between the embryonic and fatal stages
so this transition is being called the
embryonic fatal translation so yeah so
the question really is what's going on
can we recapitulate it can we an adult
and somehow give it tissues its tissues
some kind of stimulus that will reset
this and give those cells the ability to
do what cells can naturally do early on
in embryonic development in that and
that's right here in the female as the
fetus is being born right around it's
naturally that early on actually most of
it goes away well before birth some of
its instant but yeah I mean the thing is
but if we could give so that all that
like a superpower seller I guess
something like that however we've got to
ask the question we only have to ask the
question why does this happen why did
evolution create this transition why
didn't eeveelution just let the organism
retain this regenerative capacity
throughout adulthood anyway yeah and of
course there are natural answers to that
let's bring out one the first one is
well it was maybe a defense against
cancer but that's okay I mean we're
obviously getting better and better at
figuring out how to keep cancer under
control by other means but nicly we
wouldn't even acquire cancer if we were
to have that regeneration yeah that's a
very dangerous thing to say
so um cancer is a disease of aging
almost all cancers happen much more
often less in life than early right and
the reason for that is because like all
other diseases of aging it is the result
of the accumulation of a lot of a
particular type of damage in this case
damage to the DNA most of this damage
will be mutations so it will be what I
call epimutations which are not changes
to the sequence they're changes to which
well the often called the decorations
today and added to tell me which genes
are
but whether it's whichever of those two
it is the fact that you need a lot of
those things to happen in the same cell
for the cell to get to be a cancer now
those things are happening all the time
so you and I have got lots and lots of
cells that have some of those types of
DNA damage just not enough of those
types of DNA damage for us to have
cancer yet but an older person
irrespective of whether they have
regenerative cells or non regenerative
cells they've got that DNA damaged so if
we take a cell that's not regenerative
but it does have a lot of DNA damage and
we met that regenerative again that we
may be facilitating that cell becoming
cancerous sometime down the road and
that's the kind of thing that we need to
look at helping to avert if we want to
make use of this idea does Jax find it
to be there what they're doing right now
is it finding that super cell and trying
to bring that into our lives any kind of
yeah I mean basically we're interested
in identifying the molecular basis of
the transition for example genes that
are turned on before the translation
Yudof afterwards or vice versa exactly
the same kind of thing that people did
when they were trying to figure out how
to make IPS self induced pluripotent
stem cells which is which kind of
related process we you know we believe
that there is likely to be a small
number of genes the actors kind of
switches in this process same what's the
worst for IPS and we've got some handles
on some of them and of course once we
get the genes then there's reasonably
straightforward process of figuring out
how to manipulate those genes and a
quick a quick last thought about this
probably for going into the questions
would be what is your right now you're
advising biome what is emphasized that
you know that's not a big part of my
life yeah III only
and have a rather peripheral with fire
but yeah I mean my role here really is
to be there for to advise them on
aspects of metabolism and aging that I
may simply be you know useful for
however my interesting I mean it's very
much as I was saying earlier that we are
still profoundly ignorant about the role
of the microbiome in biology in general
and of course in aging in particular
even though my gut you know intuition is
that we don't need to mess directly with
the microbiome in order to benefit aging
but rather than microbiome well
spontaneously rejuvenated we were given
another thing okay nevertheless you know
I would love to be wrong it would be
great if we could manipulate the rock
microbiome in relatively simple ways
that would have widespread rejuvenating
effects in novena was mentioning how the
dot in terms of food like you were
saying even if you choose to not if you
choose to smoke yes you will die earlier
if you choose to eat shitty food you
will die slightly earlier but novena was
mentioning how the and this kind of
relates to Robert Sapolsky behave as
well but over time through evolution
your heritage where your DNA from who
you've come from and your microbiome
from again from where you've come from
as well as that moment of if you've been
eating lots of bananas over your years
and you see a banana some that free
wills and even there you eat the banana
the gut microbiome indicates to you to
eat the banana then there's then there's
also all the he was talking about et his
family lots of spinach spinach spinach
beating this thing but really his family
had was eating wheat a lot and so then
he needed to go and eat wheat did you
did you do you align kind of with that
understanding that you taken you take
some an understanding of what your body
should be eating through that it has
been through your family and through
heritage well whether or through the
heritage I'm certain that there's a
great deal of truth in the idea
that you should listen to your body in
terms of ye should be eating now the
role of the microbiome in that I think
it's very unclear none known but I
wouldn't be at all surprised if it's
quite a big role but the general
principle here is that yes evolution has
given us the ability to sense what we
need what we're short of you know
different days we'll wake up feeling in
the mood to eat or drink different
things and that's because of what
micronutrients or whatever we may be
lacking
I'm really interested to see if that's
this was right procedure to take in well
what is it Asus ending in of salaat as
it's live oh oh there are many different
ways to figure out the gut what think of
what's what's right for you individually
person yeah I mean you think if it
changes from one week to the next right
it's something that is consequent on
what you have been eating and what you
might have been sure self so you know
the general principle of not even
thinking about why to read it what
you're reading books or what your blood
numbers say but actually just doing what
feels right works pretty well of course
you can get it can get deranged you know
if people get into it I mean people
often say for example that the reason
why we have an obesity epidemic now is
because historically we evolved in a
scenario in which food was scarce yeah
and when food what we had a spike you
know when fit was suddenly abundant yeah
it would like you to be abundant only
very briefly and so we had to make the
most of it and we're not very good at
adapting that to a situation in which
foods are burned all the time yeah
I'll breathe this this has been very
very enriching okay thank you and let's
let's ask you about a couple of these
questions that have really been on my
mind so it seems as though and you you
know you you mentioned this on the
previous time we sat down that you
weren't so concerned about artificial
general intelligence but let's put that
to the side is that still true that is
well I wouldn't say I'm not concerned I
think it may turn out that the concern
is unfounded because the hard takeoff
the rapid acceleration of influence and
power of AI may simply be mathematically
impossible however that's a speculation
we just don't know okay and then the
second issue that I think is very
pressing for an existential conversation
about society is the rapid accumulation
of wealth by only a select few people
compared to the bottom people on the
planet and also the fact that then that
amplifies their ability to gain access
to cryptocurrency to biotechnology to AI
and robotics to all the different things
that are going to augment them faster
than the rest of population do you think
there needs to be done something about
that gap or do you and what do you think
about it it's that's above my pay grade
I feel like you have an answer I really
don't I mean I'm not an economist I
haven't no idea but I think what you
were referencing to earlier about how
you know vitalik and other people that
are that are younger have some sort of
more of a collective potential for this
okay yeah I mean I really dive I think
it's little about and then what are we
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world
haha my hot tub
you probably say my fiancee quickly yeah
yeah add that one in there it's good
okay okay do you think there's an
inherent meaning or purpose to life not
I I think that the search for such a
thing is purely a psychological
phenomenon I really you know I've never
been a philosopher I'm just the first
thing for pragmatic practical kind of
guy do you think that there is a way
that to maximize human potential that
you'd recommend well I guess it's kind
of the same question in a way you know
I'm gonna say I don't think the life a
web saying that more personally would be
that I know that what I want to do with
my life is to make a difference to
people's standard of living people's
quality of life but when you ask if you
were to ask me why is that what I want
to do with my life
which is a more abstract question away
for me then I will happily tell you I
have no idea why that's what I want to
do with my life and I will also tell you
perfectly happily so I don't care that I
don't know right that I'm perfectly fine
just accepting that that is who I am
right so you know again human potential
you know what's that you know it's it's
different for different people do you
think we're alone in the cosmos my
preferred answer of the many answers
that exist to the Fermi paradox you know
they're you know where is everybody one
my preferred answer is the cloaking
answer that says that the reason we
don't see any other civilizations it's
not because civilizations always you
know destroy themselves immediately
after becoming smart enough to have any
transmission but rather that
it's it it it ends up not being all that
difficult to avoid transmission to
actually just stop emitting you know
electromagnetic signatures of one's
existence and if one can do that easily
once one can do it easily then why not
you know because there's always some
chance that there might be some
aggressive alien species out there
looking for you know other species to
destroy and the best way to stop that
from happening is to make sure you're
not discovered so that would also I mean
even if that the probability that there
is such an aggressive species is
extremely low you know if it turns out
if it ends up being really easy to cloak
yourself then why not just do it do you
think there are advanced civilizations
roaming the cosmos on balance I would
say probably not you know if you know if
you are such a species you're probably
not the only one right and therefore
they're gonna destroy each other even if
they don't destroy the cloaked ones
right so and you think this is base
reality or simulation oh that's a tricky
one I rather like the simulation
argument I think that the the
impossibility of determining empirically
whether you're in a simulation and the
fact that simulations could be iterative
right that a simulated universe can have
you know individuals that create their
own simulated universe and so on you
know that leads to the rather attractive
conclusion that were very unlikely to be
not a simulation but you know there are
ways out of that argument and what is
something that you believe to be true
that almost nobody else believes to be
true well I mean that's obvious isn't
that you know
aging is a manager ever ever amenable to
foreseeable medical intervention aging
is a foreseeable medical intervention
amenable to amenable to foreseeable
medical intervention
Virgen and and and to give people the
choice to live a healthy forever
to stay healthy forever that's right yep
thank you dr. Aubrey de Grey thank you
this has been a pleasure everyone at
home if you guys had a good time please
like comment subscribe do check out Sons
org join please because this is really
important as Aubrey said there's a lot
of people saying that this is the right
thing that you've nailed it you know
what it is and it's just now time to put
some money into it so that they can go
further so check them out give them a
donation I want to give a shout out to
you at home thanks for tuning in
do share the content with other people
support us on patreon when you pay for
our studio our lights our electricity
our camera equipment our guests to have
a good time while they're here and thank
you very much to our producer and
director around Vargas and thank you and
we'll see you again tomorrow thank you
or not tomorrow but soon
you